hi and welcome to the precision medicine
virtual event
my name is Seth Crosby and I am at
Washington University specifically am at
the McDonald genome Institute there I'm
going to be talking about rare alleles
specifically the title of my talk is
tissue and CF DNA rare alleles how low
can we go please feel free to submit
questions during my presentation or you
can email me and I'll follow up with you
if I can
okay we're on my first slide and I just
wanted to say that we're now actually an
amalgam of two different facilities were
the one that I started genome technology
access center and the Auguste McDonald
genome Institute we were combined into a
single facility here's my email address
you are most welcome to to contact me
just a quick description of our facility
most of the work we do is research but
we do do some clinical work as well
we're cap CLIA certified we have even
the New York State certification we do a
lot of different genomic tests and again
if that's of interest to you that's
great it's just the talk I'm going to be
talking about today is relatively
clinically based so I just wanted to
mention this okay so a few years ago we
decided to a G tach we decided to start
a clinical sequencing facility and one
of the first panels we used was a cancer
panel this we we brought this panel
online about the same time the
foundation got started with theirs
and as you can see ours had about 20 odd
genes in it and wild foundations had 400
we did this because we wanted to have a
panel that was that was covered by CMS
and by various payers
and so we started off with a very a very
modest panel it was a biotinylated Beit
panel not an amplicon panel and it
allowed for very deep sequencing this is
the current state of the panel you could
see that it's grown to some degree and
I'd be happy to send you more
information on that so I said I
mentioned to you that on the the panel
allows for deep sequencing and the
question is why we need deep sequencing
specifically in this in the situation
with oncology the problem is is that as
I mentioned to you a lot of times
oncology DNA or the I'm sorry malignant
DNA is present at a relatively minor
amount in in samples so you'll have for
example of you can see here there's a
whole bunch of the EGF each of these
lines represents a sample you can see
that there's a couple of genes that are
sticking out in the middle of there and
we might this those G's might be
clinically significant or they may
actually be sequencing errors the
sequencers are not perfect and every now
and then either by PCR or the sequencing
itself an error can be introduced and
the question we're going to be talking
about today is how do we distinguish
between true mutations and sequencing
errors this is from a paper that came
out a few years ago where they were
actually looking at tumor tissue and
they determined that there were a number
of different mutations present in
different physical areas in the in this
renal sarcoma and actually the majority
of the tumors were not universal across
the entire tumor so this is sort of
reminds us that the tumors can be
polyclonal and sometimes the clone of
interest may not be the main clone one
of the authors said something kind of
funny he said I'm still depressed about
it if I'm honest if we had higher
resolution assays the complexity would
be far worse
so tumors are complicated tissue in
addition the pathologists in the
audience will recognize the fact that
the section we're looking at is mostly
normal that the tumor really is only
these shaded part and the rest of it is
just fibrotic tissue so in addition to
the fact that a tumor can be polyclonal
even a monoclonal tumor that the
material of interest may only be the
minor material in this section okay so
at the when when you when you come out
with any kind of a clinical test even a
lab develop test the first thing you
need to do is to is to test it to
validate it to make sure that it works
properly and more importantly when you
validate it you you want to figure out
what the sensitivity is how low can you
go what's that we if I talk to you about
the complicated situation with with
cancer how far down can you go in terms
of sensitivity in terms of the ability
to detect mutations so we came out with
this paper and I'm just going to show
you a single image from the paper just
one of the one of the many facets that
we tested when we were testing this new
panel and we did a very simple test is
that we just took two defined DNA
samples called hapmap samples these are
DNA samples which have been rigorously
tested and we mixed them together so we
took a lot of one and a little bit of
another and we mixed them together to
see how far down we could go to detect
the allele in the minor population of
what we mixed so we mixed it 5050 twenty
eighty ten ninety et cetera
in addition to the to the physical
mixing we also did some down sampling we
did we did mixing in silico to further
the the sequencing test and this is one
of the figures that we did
um so when we this was looking at a
heterozygote allele so we mixed 50-50
but you can see that the the top number
there is 25% because it was ahead and
and we on the x-axis you can see what
the coverage was and I told you that
that that original panel allowed for a
thousand X coverage but we went ahead
and down sampled from 1200 down to a
hundred coverage and you can see that it
25% that that we were able to detect
that allele down to about 200 full
coverage when you drop to 10% the data
still looks pretty good even it even at
nine hundred eight hundred seven hundred
full coverage we were able to detect
that minor allele as soon as we drop
down to 5% however we lost the ability
to detect the minor allele and so just
simplistically speaking that the story's
a little bit more complex but
simplistically seeking we said okay
we've got a clinical test and were able
to detect a minor allele down to 10%
anything less than 10% we probably won't
be able to call that so this was using
an aligner that was available at the
time but what we wanted to do while we
were doing this if she wanted to look at
other methods for detecting rare
variants
this was another paper that came out
actually leave it exactly the same time
and David an error or testing other
variant detectors GTA gatk is one is the
one that we were using for this clinical
test but they decided to compare this
with Sam tools and then a couple of
detectors that were that were created to
detect rare alleles so for example
splinter you actually use spike in DNA
in order to be able to define what the
error rate is and their scan to also is
it uses base quality filters to be able
to detect a more rare allele these
these were in I know this when she was
and I think the veriscan was as well
they were used back when sequencing was
kind of expensive and people like to to
pool samples together and so that they
were able to they were still looking for
constituent of alleles but because they
were pooled together they weren't there
on a 50/50 level
okay so again the paper is a little bit
more sense of than what I'm going to
show you but what we did was um we
basically took five hapmap samples and
we we identified from our cancer panel
427 heterozygotes that were common
across those five hapmap samples and we
used the the variants had to be detected
by both of our standard variant
detecting tools G Tech and Sam tools I'm
sorry gatk and Sam tools at greater than
50% detection rate and so a little bit
like with the other experiment that I
described we took those two hapmap
samples we mix them together at various
concentration we used our panel to
enrich for the regions that we were
targeting those those oncology genes and
we sequenced mapped by Nova line and
then use the various detection tools
that I just mentioned and compared them
so here are the five hapmap samples that
we used and what we did was we use this
was sort of our scope our soda
sample right here nine eight nine and
here's the four scotches that we mixed
with it and we mixed it again I said
half and half 20% etc then when looking
at those heterozygotes those heads now
for a half and a half the hats would be
present at twenty five ten five and etc
etc
so the first thing we did was we looked
at to try and see how many false
negatives we have so here are the four
tools again these are the standard tools
gatk and Sam tools and then here are the
the more sensitive tools for our scan
and splinter and here on the x-axis you
see we're diluting our allele of
interest out with 25 to 2.5% and the
first thing you notice is that the
standard illegal detector which was
bitten was what's built to detect him
either a homozygote or a heterozygote
doesn't do a particularly good job
detecting a rare allele even at 25
percent Sam tool starts to degrade a
little bit and then this gap right here
where you see zeros that Sam tools
zeroing out it's no longer able to
detect that variant and that's not
surprising because it was not designed
to detect it gee a TTA does a better job
it's able to detect to some degree down
to 5% but it zeros out again at 2.5%
whereas the variant detection tools that
were designed to detect low-frequency
alleles did a pretty good job looking at
specificity now we're going to look at
false positives and as our teachers and
college told us what you give up in
sensitivity you gain in specificity and
what you can see is that we're raising
false positives on them on the y-axis
and you can see that gatk and Sam tools
had a relatively small number of false
positives as a matter of fact the gas
cycle where Sam tools that you can see
those zeros again on the on the x-axis
indicating that there were no false
positives from Sam tools all the way
down to 5% or 2.5% heterozygote presence
whereas ver seek and splinter you can
actually see interestingly that
splinters a number of false positives
increased as as the allele frequency
went down
and veriscan was relatively own constant
so if you if you just look here sort of
as a kind of a six mile up comparison on
the green indicates good the yellow not
so hot and red is not great at all we
could say that splinter sort of takes
the award because it was very sensitive
as it's designed to be and it wasn't too
bad in terms of specificity you can see
here that splinter even you know even it
at five percent had had was was still
not a lot of false positives and I put a
little silver medal there next to next
to splinter but I want to remind you
that these these tests were run a few
years ago and they are constantly
reversion these little testers and you
really need to repeat this experiment
with current data to be able to
determine whether or not you know what
your what your sensitivity is currently
all right so so what we've been talking
about up until now is detecting DNA
derived from solid tumors on now we're
going to go over to cell free DNA in the
case of oncology it's also called CT DNA
or circulating tumor DNA this DNA was
first circulating free DNA DNA was first
noted in the in plasma in 1948 it was
noted to be elevated in cancer patients
in 1977 and vogelstein started looking
at those mutations and being able to
detect rare mutations using a method
called beam in 2007 circulating tumor
DNA doesn't hang around in plasma very
long that's only there for less than an
hour
and the the presence of the allele can
be very low that just basically put a
question mark and can be as high
is one out of every 100 it could even be
higher than that I've been told and so
is here you what you have miss just some
vessels that are running through a tumor
and the tumor cells you know are no
crime no crossing and releasing DNA into
circulation and this is thought to be at
least in the case of solid tumors how
circulating free DNA is released and
this can be a primary tumor it can be a
very small met but and this is a way to
detect the presence of tumor without
actually having to biopsy so as I said
the the minor alleles in in serum or in
plasma can be very minor indeed and and
there's there the problem remains is how
do you detect an allele that's that's
extremely minor one nice thing if you
knew if you were for example if you had
identified an allele in in your tumor
and you put you could look for the
presence of an allele that you'd
previously identified in the tumor or
you could look at common mutations
medically actionable mutations that that
have already been identified and are
often present in about 85% of malignancy
so would be nice for example you could
design a PCR analysis where you could
see here that the we have two templates
here with germline template in a mutant
template and the primer is is sets down
on the DNA in the presence of the mutant
template but it doesn't match in the
presence of germline so great you just
run a PCR analysis and if the if you get
a product then you know the mutant is
present in in the in in the plasma the
problem is that the the PCR tends to be
relatively it tends to be a little bit
leaky in other words somehow the
polymerase is able to get around that
non annealing on-base and so for example
this is some data that was generated in
at IDT
one of our companies that we work with
and the company I'm going to be talking
about that invented the the next
technology that I'm going to describe
and you can see in these in these two
tables this is some rt-pcr this is this
is um quantitative PCR and what what you
can see is that the the number of cycles
on the on the x axis indicates how much
material is present and when it so that
the more material that's present the the
fewer cycles are required in order to
make a product and so Eve in the kinases
case of a midst mismatch um see the a
mismatch and a teenag mismatch on the
left on the right you can see that there
really is just about 1 or 2 cycles
difference between the wild type and the
mismatch meaning that the the tach
polymerase can can get around that
mismatched base it seems to take a
little hit a couple of cycles difference
but not very much certainly not enough
to be able to detect a or an allele that
was less than you know say 1% of the
total number of DNA copies so IDT came
up with a very clever method for for
addressing this it's called a blocked
cleavable primer and what it does is it
takes a primer which is in is here it's
on the left side you can see it's a it's
in black the green is the template and
in the DNA prime where they introduce
one RNA base so you can see there's a u
on the on the black primer and they also
block the primer so they put they put a
just some group on the end of the primer
to make it so that so that the
polymerase cannot use the primer to
prime off of and then they take
advantage of an enzyme called RNA CH one
and what are
h-1 does is it Cleaves RNA and Cleaves
RNA when there is an RNA DNA complex so
in this case you can see that one you is
that's the RNA and it's bound to or
hybridize to the green DNA template so
you have an rna-dna hybrid there and so
the RNA h1 recognizes that and it
cleaves it so you can see there on the
left side that the the blocking moiety
has been cleaved off whereas if the
alright if the RNA is not hybridized to
the DNA as you can see below the
cleavage doesn't work and then the block
remains there's another picture of it so
now what you can see here is that on the
left side without adding any enzyme with
no RNA s-- the the qpcr creates no
product because the the primer is
blocked so cycle after cycle after cycle
nothing happens nothing is produced when
you add our own ace now the primer
becomes unblocked and you're able to get
product and so this is the this is
thought to be and and as you'll see it's
a much better way much better at
distinguishing between a mutant and a
wild-type allele so this is just an
example of this experiment in this case
what they've done is they they've run
out an experiment where you have a on
the on the on the lower two graphs you
can see that there's this is there's a
mismatch where they're not adding any
I'm sorry so on the top two graphs you
have this you have the same mismatch and
you have the same slight delay in
inquire in PCR because it because it's
not settling down right on the bottom
two you have blocked primers and so what
you see now is you have a delay of about
12 cycles before
product starts to get formed this
indicates that the process unlike the
slide here above where you see that it
just goes on and on indefinitely in
actuality what IDT and what we found is
that there even even using these block
primers just a little bit of leakage and
I don't really know why that leakage
occurred but but 12 cycles that's 2 to
the power of 12 that's a numbers you
know a very large number in terms of the
required amount of the Leal before you
actually start to have product so what
we did was we we asked them for reagents
that they had generated internally and
looked to seeing how much of a delay we
had comparing a wild-type versus a
mutation and so what we did was we took
the mutant and we diluted it I'm going
to just sort of read across I wish I had
my cursor but we diluted it 1 to 1 1 to
10 1 to 100 etc until there was actually
no mutant there at all and and what we
could see is we were able to demonstrate
using these block primers with this was
done in duplicate that's why you have
two colors and I'm sorry that the the 1
to 10,000 is is yellow and it's probably
very hard to see but it's it's there out
there with the negative controls what we
were able to determine is that we were
able to distinguish a mutant versus a
wild-type allele out to one to five
thousand dilution and this is pretty
good the one to ten thousand is mixed up
there with the negative controls when we
weren't able to detect that so we this
worked very well for the IDT
[Music]
templates and we decided we would test
our own so we took some classic oncology
mutations the EGFR KS e RB 2 jak 2 and
fgfr2 and we decided we used again to
find hapmap samples to be able to see
whether or not
these blocked reagents could distinguish
between mutant and wild type STIs were
defined mutants we tested both the top
and the bottom strand and what I what
are the pairs of primers are indicated
there in brown and blue you can see the
mutation is being detected by the
blocked primer and then we have a sister
primer which is either there in the blue
creating the blue prayer or there in the
brown creating the the brown hair so
that's why every mutation here except
for the EGFR that has two different
mutations as indicated by the RS numbers
every mutation has four rows what we're
doing is where we are matching both the
top we're using the pair of primers for
both the top and the bottom strand so
one pair of primers per top or bottom
strand mutation and what we did find
first of all was simply just to test the
primers to see if they worked and we
would we put the primers on their
defined templates I'm sorry you can see
here that in this little colored table
the five rows the NA numbers those are
hapmap samples and this defines whether
the hapmap sample in the columns here
were the mutations and whether the
hapmap samples were reference
heterozygous or homozygous the reds are
homozygous yellow is heterozygous and
green is reference so we were able to
mix these hapmap samples together and in
to determine to be able to see what the
sensitivity was for these various
mutants so first we didn't do any mixing
we just went ahead and tested how the
primers did on there in the presence of
our NH RNA h1 so these were unblocked
primers that you can see that not all
the primers worked and anyone doing PCRs
wouldn't be surprised by that then what
we did was we did another mixing assay
where we mixed the variant together with
the reference
and so in this case on the y-axis were
seeing the CT so the lower the CT is the
more product was formed on the on the
left side of each so and then on the on
the x-axis you can see each of those is
a different mutation and on the the in
on the and the for each of these groups
on the leftmost bar the the dark blue
bar means that we had no variant present
at all so it wouldn't detect anything
and we should be able that we should get
no product the first thing you notice is
that in some cases we did get product
because we would have CT so you can see
in the EE RB B we had CTS of around
thirty one so you could slightly get
some product and in cases we didn't see
anything the other thing is that as you
as we go across those colors um we're
adding more and more of the mutant you
can see there in red the number of
copies of mutant we added so what we
want to see is we want to see the CTS
dropping with each addition we see the
CT dropping at least after you know
after the there's so the first dilution
is one in twenty thousand so we didn't
really expect to see much there but
after that one in ten thousand one in
five thousand we wanted to be able to
see that and in the case of Jack we saw
a very nice demonstration of the
detection of the rare allele we can see
re B twos as well but we didn't see it
in all cases and what we were hoping for
is we were hoping to be able to use
these blocked primers to be able to
create a universal test and we didn't
and when we were talking about this with
IDT they had ideas about each a say
about how we might be able to increase
the productivity but we we didn't want
to have each assay be unique we wanted
to be able to do this in the high
throughput so we
tucked away from this from this idea
okay so I'm gonna talk now continue to
talk about rare illegal I'm going to
talk about something a little bit more
recent for us um and this is using a
concept which is actually not
particularly recent we've had unique
molecular barcodes for about a decade
but we've applied a tweak to it that
that's made it rather relatively
sensitive and for those in the audience
who are not familiar with unique
molecular indexes I'm going to just
briefly describe this so you can see
here in the top blue bars you can see
that those some some of the fragments
contain mutants which are indicated by
the green stars some of them don't and
you remember in one of my early images
the question if that if that mutant is
really rare is that is that mutant real
or is that mutant is that or are we are
we seeing a PCR air or a sequencing
error so what we do is we take our
fragmented DNA and we attach a unique
bar code to each DNA and the way this is
done is you basically just have eight or
twelve or sixteen random nucleotides um
that are added so when you take enough
random nucleotides you can get you can
get a huge number of different unique
sequences and this is done by instead of
synthesizing an ASE or G or T in a
certain position you simply just assign
an N so ACGT is added randomly to the
first position ACGT is random added
randomly to the second position and the
number of possible all of the
nucleotides that you can get from that
is can be calculated by ad to the power
of whatever number of nucleotides you're
adding so for example for a logo that's
only 2 bases long you have 16 possible
but 4 bases long you have 4 to the power
of 4 16 bases long you have 4 to the
power of 16 you can see how this number
gets very
large very quickly and you get a very
unique Oliver nucleotides so anyhow you
add these unique Oliver nucleotides to
the to the fragments and then you go
ahead and amplify them now what you'll
see is that you get these things called
reads families and a read family is all
of the progeny from a single unique
molecular barcode single um eyes
so all those read one two three four
that was all arose from the original
fragment they're they're there they came
from a single fragment and you can see
that there are every single fragment
contains that green mutation another
natural mutation which existed at the
beginning of experiment and you also
have some variants in there which are
not common to the Reed family and so by
using these um eyes were able to be able
to detect what was there at the
beginning or very early on in the
experiment unfortunately some mutation
is added very early in the process it's
a little hard to distinguish that from a
PCR error and that is why later on when
I'm talking I'm going to say talk about
the importance of doing a technical
replicate on this but this is a way of
being able to distinguish a PCR error
from an actual mutation
so Todd drooly who until recently was at
Washington University and he was there
when he had invented this method or this
variation of the UM I method created
something called error corrected
sequencing there are a couple of
references there that you are welcome to
read and this is sort of the workflow
that he did it's similar to what I
talked about with a couple but with some
of some additions so again you take
genomic DNA and amplify amplify with you
with basically you're in your enriching
genomic DNA for four regions that are of
interest you could be using biotin
elated baits you could be using amplicon
sequencing the second
as you add you a my adapters those
unique molecular barcodes to each
amplicon they sorted so it's a very low
amplification to start with then you add
the um eyes and then you you go ahead
and amplify up enough so that you're
able to create a PCR I mean a sequencing
library the libraries are very carefully
quantified by digital droplet PCR so
precisely the same amount of library is
added into the sequencing this is one
variation that the Todd brought in the
weeds are aligned and then you have them
grouped into read families which I was
talking about the sequencing errors that
are randomly distributed amongst mean
families while the true variants are
pressing all members of the read family
another thing that I didn't add on here
and I should have I'm sorry
the the both the top and the bottom
strand are a sequence and so this gives
you two shots at the at the same
fragment is you you would need to have
that a real mutation appearing twice and
as I mentioned before you have you do
this with using technical duplicates
using this method Todd was able to get
down to a sensitivity of about one in
10,000 he was able to do discovery in
terms in one in 10,000 here we he's
doing a same experiment similar to what
we were talking about where he's taking
a mutant DNA and diluting it into
wild-type DNA from one to one down to
one to 10 mm and you can see that the
the his the observation that he made out
of the sequencing is comparable to what
the theoretical presence of the of the
minor allele should have been there was
one other slide in here I didn't include
it I'm sorry
the just as a little plug for a local
st. Louis company they have the the
technique that I just described was
patented by Washington University and
canape
Sciences has a exclusive access to this
technology you're welcome to contact
them if you'd like to have access to to
this they give you there's a little
picture here of their the report that
comes out it's very nice all right so
that's pretty much all I need to talk
about in terms of the work that we've
been doing for rare allele detection at
Washington University just in closing
sort of some kind of clinical questions
one is that you know we talk about the
the desirability of becoming more and
more sensitive but at some point the
sensitivity ceases to be an issue
because you know you taking a normal
tube of blood you don't necessarily get
that many copies of of a rare allele in
a normal tube of blood and so the
sensitivity should never exceed to
exceed the amount of blood that you're
taking from a patient and then there are
some biomedical considerations as well
is that our tourists necessarily DNA
leaky are medically actionable tumors
actually releasing DNA into the
circulation are we are we do we bias
ourselves toward the the more vulnerable
parts of the tumor whereas the healthier
parts of the tumor are not necrosis and
therefore not released in DNA into
circulation and then at what point are
detected malignant mutations actually
medically actionable so thank you very
much for your time you have different
ways of getting in contact with me I
need to change this last slide that's my
that's my daughter who's just getting
ready to go to college so the slide the
pictures a little bit old that's it and
go blues